stay on this path what would you say to
what do you think about all this [ __ ]
where people like we don't want our kids
playing football anymore
when I reflect listen man I think with
with football
it's here's Brendan Schaub I'm fine
football controversy what I hear right
now
do you us find the Tim Dylan chop
[Music]
last night miles Garrett took a
quarterback helmet off and hit him with
it
okay spending for the season that's too
much I think way too much way too much a
game yes it's the culture we live in
where everything's like this this you
know cam you should have hit a woman
keep going if you're gonna hit a woman
if you're gonna do it hit your partner
and you're probably next game or the
USCS on you
[Music]
transgender children playing football
sure like icebox weary oneness [ __ ] your
planet like this is a huge problem now
you have women identifying these men
no you have man identifying his women
and then they beat up women that when it
comes on when it comes to mixed martial
arts that's weird
that's strength but that's the only part
where it's strange really what about
cycling what about you know old men have
all these advantages and then they take
hormones then they become women and then
they dominate no sports is that fair you
don't care ok so you're breaking with
Rogan and hitch cliff on this
Brendan Schaub for trans athletes
interesting ok whatever may if it's
wrestling it's a little dicey it's a
little dicey if it's cycling don't care
and most people know this about you you
were you were huge supporter and you
funded Donald Trump's campaign whip what
do you think about Donald Trump Donald
Trump as president of the United States
two-term Trump um I don't feel the same
way about him we think he's funny he
probably shouldn't be the present that's
literally the way he's a celebrity who
surprise shouldn't be the president I
think the majority of very fun he's very
funny hilarious I think majority of
Americans are sick of politicians and
ones like that we try to burn it - it
could have been anybody we're burning
the system they could absolutely when
I'm making Logan Paul president we've
talked about it a bunch on the show I'm
not gonna talk about it again I'm done
for that but it will happen I'm telling
you is kinda his brother being the in
the house is gonna keep his brother pay
a little bit less like Jake we gotta win
like Jake we gotta tone it down there
you got toned it down a bit we're gonna
work with a fine Jake we'll do
agriculture we'll put himself out of
Tony we don't work with Logan first
um when you hear politicians going
millionaires of the problem rich people
of the problem you're somebody who has a
lot of money yes what do you feel like
when you hear that when you hear Bernie
Sanders or people like that now they're
not necessarily talking about you
they're talking about the billionaire
class I'm at the 0.001 percent right but
does it make sense a person and their
9.00 one it would come after pitchforks
for years [ __ ] because because I
wear this the people they're just angry
at rich people how do you think maybe
they're misguided because some of them
have a point some have a point the
people's families and agree that
billions of dollars forever but people
are self-made entrepreneurs you
shouldn't touch them that's [ __ ] up
yeah that's the American dream right
right are you doing I know immigration
more less even girlfriend he's Mexican
born and raised if she is she illegally
do it real interesting now do you ever
threaten her a little called the
authority if she gets wise every
Thursday thing American Isaac can she
read and ride and everything kind of
okay he was tough a little bit right
she's in and that's probably smoking
she's cool very attractive yeah good
mother good mother Mexican dude yeah of
course you're very nurturing warm this
does she make a bundle a what's that
kicked open the most open something like
that yeah she killed it with the
enchiladas which kills with enchiladas
then they she ordered the Mexican made
around and it's that interesting dynamic
who hears that right because she hears
the answering dynamic is next image ever
like yeah I know you think you're a
white [ __ ] you're in a white [ __ ] yes
I bet we know where you come from a la
Jara
how do you feel about society when you
look at what's happening on social media
and YouTube and things like that does it
make you feel confident where society's
going I think it's gonna balance out I
think now we're like just realizing how
addictive social media is how it's like
this bullying thing with young kids and
kids who commit suicide
there's like this cancel culture and
this hate culture on there and it's a
it's a good thing that's also super
negative and I think it's gonna sway
back over here and now you see how
Instagram is you can't see likes anymore
screaming followers out oh you think so
well this is what they did with Facebook
they started playing around with it and
then it just became like a haven for
boomers to scream at each other well
it's also like how hot - any of these
things stay forever young kids are on
tick-tock now right I don't like to talk
you take toxic are you on there no I
should be you know tick-tock it's that
thing where people are dancing to
falling down there do crazy things
15 seconds on videos they have all those
tick-tock crisps like boomerang yeah
that's like boomer it's like a 15-second
like a vine but longer and and it's all
those cringe compliment garfi our friend
racism there no they can't buy tickets
you're right but I'm just saying when
you look at like at one point dozing me
something they sticks around Twitter's
around right what is it was going away
but the Trump energized it and it became
political I like I like Twitter a lot
because you can put things out people
could share them relatively easily yeah
I think what we're gonna learn is social
media and you're given these these kind
of these dark demons of voice where it
gives them credibility to hate on
successful people or hate on talented
people and that and also bully kids so I
think it's gonna even out we're like oh
[ __ ] this isn't giving everybody a voice
in a giving them opinion it's not good
so Brendan Schaub here on the Tim Dylan
show for taking away the internet from
oh only losers do not everyone should be
able to communicate on social media and
they shouldn't be able to say agree they
should be able to communicate to certain
people you know the problem is access is
that says astute if we've got rid of
that fourth what we don't right now
let's I wanna we're talking about walls
build that wall build that wall on
social media build that wall to the
people in their dads basements to me
well there's a lot of people I think
that here's what's scary when you find
out on social media I think a lot of
people are in basements a lot of people
are in their dad's basement there's a
lot of anger there's a lot of mental
illness 100% but there's also it's their
own mental illness yeah you know I'm
standing and it comes out and I think
researchers find like oh this isn't good
it's not good what do you tell those
people that want to change your life
what should they do let's say somebody's
watching this and they used to hate you
stop watching them stop watching it's a
great lets stop watching this except
given five we need five minutes to the
down yeah